dans la sphère du petit grégory les
événements se sont accélérés depuis hier
en début d'après-midi auditions de
plusieurs témoins et surtout publication
d'un portrait robot du meurtrier que la
famille ne se décide toujours pas
dénoncer si elle le connaît sur place
notre envoyé spécial isabelle enquêteurs
ont bien cru être sur une piste qui hier
concernant les assassins éventuelle de
grégory à 17h30 une femme qui veut
garder l'anonymat
elle se cache dans sa voiture arrive à
la gendarmerie elle appartient d'assez
loin au clan villemin la branche
paternelle et elle a des soupçons à ses
yeux deux couple d'ouvriers de filature
du petit village voisin de l'avs line
pourrait être coupable
il s'agit de gaston et margret au lard
la soixantaine de leur fils daniel et de
chantal sa femme
18h les deux couples sont amenés à la
gendarmerie après une perquisition à
leur domicile
nous les avons retrouvés ce matin à un
moment délicat ce que j'avais fait
mardi ont marre des livres j'ai sans fil
du travail à 21h à 1h sur les huîtres
action à la filature de la grogne d'un
menu ratissant les gones et six robots
mais j'ai jamais connu ce robot moi je
connais pas jacquot dit aux journalistes
quittent alors je connais pas ce robot
vous n'avez pas une idée il a parce que
ici dans cette partie de la famille vous
voyez assez peu les
il m'a plu
quand on s'engage pas mais la libye
était solide
à 1h30 du matin les deux couples
ressortent de la gendarmerie
ébranlé par le longue interrogatoire
mais soulagé les gendarmes doivent
admettre que cette piste n'a rien donné
il faut tout recommencer à zéro